you'll not be at all surprised that it's
because people like you who are spending
a lot of time and energy in developing
markets we've seen a very dramatic
increase in foreign direct investment
going to the emerging markets over the
last 20 years really a huge boom post
1995 and despite the drop after the.com
bust and a lot of things that were
happening worldwide I will pick up again
in the last several years two main
drivers behind this is the actual
liberalisation of foreign direct
investment regulations which limited a
lot of foreign direct investment into
many of these markets in the past and in
many cases just improvements in
telecommunications power infrastructure
otherwise that have made some of these
investments attractive now when they
were not attractive before so we decided
from the McKinsey Global Institute side
to try to find out what's behind all
this what's really happening what does
this mean in terms of the activities the
multinational companies are taking on
what does it mean in terms of the impact
on the host economies output employment
productivity prices product selection
etc and and that's what I'll share with
you today just a range of the case
studies that we conducted in order to
inform those questions we did a total of
14 case studies you'll see that they
span a wide variety of industries from
hardcore manufacturing auto to softer
consumer electronics to some of the
services not just the lots of body
services like retail and banking but
also the IT services and business
process operations particularly in
Indian phenomenon we looked at four
major markets they're all very large
developing markets but you'll appreciate
that they have wide variety of
approaches to regulation and
macroeconomic conditions and with all of
this we thought we would be able to
develop the granular perspectives that
would allow the kind of pattern
recognition that we seek now to
interpret what we learned
these case studies I'm going to elevate
you up to the bird's-eye view for a
minute to say what is it the companies
are doing if we were trying to explain
from one level above the process that
companies are going through and what's
really happening is they enter these
markets we would do so across all these
sectors and a lot of other work we've
done at McKinsey and describe it as a
process that fits neatly into five
stages of increasing global economic
integration increasing sophistication in
the way you think about how companies
are integrating things globally not
necessarily sequential companies can
jump around these but these do speak to
higher degrees of sophistication higher
degrees of global economic integration
so I'm going to tell you what these five
are and then just spend a minute on each
of them using our case studies and our
sectors to explain what we mean by these
in the first instance simplest form is a
company takes its operations just as it
developed them in its home country and
puts them into the new market this way
achieving new customer segments open
your markets but it's just a replication
of the business model into these new
markets second one you have that but
with at the company level specialization
by product and so you see an entire
value chain being put in one location
but a different value chain or different
product or service or other capability
in a different country and using trade
as a way to optimize the production
platform so to speak the third stage is
a little more interesting and it's a
little more new where you see companies
disaggregating the value chains taking
pieces of the value chain from beginning
to end and putting them in locations
according to the specialization of those
locations that could be low-cost labor
in many cases in other cases it could be
specialized skills or otherwise and
we've begun to see that a lot more not
just in the context of developing
country FDI but just broadly the fourth
and fifth stages are really the things
that in our mind
make for a much more interesting and
very new dynamic and it really is steps
on the integration of large economies
like China and India into value chains
and the fourth stage we characterized as
having disaggregated pieces of the value
chain taking those pieces and
reconsidering how those are done to take
advantage of very different locations as
I said I'll come back to this in a
minute but it's something that we're
beginning to see much more taking place
in China and India then then and and not
seen much of it before them fifth is
stage is where you do see companies
taking advantage of specialization in
multiple markets the specific advantage
of those locations you can see very
radical shifts in the cost of delivering
those products in the production
function of delivering those products
and the result is whole new markets
become viable so let me spend a little
bit of time on each of these and bring
them to life with the sector cases first
one new market entry straightforward
stuff this has been going on for decades
but examples that we looked at here were
particularly in retail where you have
opening of FDI in Brazil in other places
and you have the replication of the
entire business system in those markets
second stage again it's been around for
a while but it's worth noting the
process by which companies take for
example the auto manufacturers began to
specialize the products in two different
markets so you had the lower value-added
products being done not just assembly
but across the chain initially in
markets like Mexico the higher
value-added products in the US and using
the trade agreements in effect to trade
the effect it was pretty dramatic when
you look at it from a Productivity point
of view what you saw were much much
higher capacity utilizations in the
plants because you didn't need the
switching you didn't need the the tail
into the markets and
dramatically increases in productivity
now we switch to the third stage now in
the third stage we have the
disaggregated value chain probably the
best example is what we see happening in
the PC world across consumer electronics
really but our PCs are among the best
examples dozens and dozens of countries
represented through different component
parts where the cost is competed and
therefore you get real pockets of
specialization with pieces of the value
chain in effect dispersed assembly in a
final location typically very close to
the consumer finally within this of
course the most recently debated and and
feared aspect of disaggregation is what
we've been seeing happening in the
services sector with offshoring of
services and this as you can see from
the various locations that we've looked
into it is a very large market India is
already 12 billion Ireland 8 and all
growing very very rapidly now we move
into the fourth and fifth stages quickly
I'm going to use an example from
services but the dynamic you can see
elsewhere the first half of this
waterfall chart is the level of savings
that are possible by migrating a task
from a developer location to a developer
in a location in this case to India but
but the example holds in many cases and
most of this you can really describe as
a task migration you're taking what was
done somewhere before the way it was
done before and you're just taking
advantage of lower cost labor the next
phase of this in effect really speaks to
taking advantage of a very different
dimension of those markets consider this
in a developed world context the
operating cost structure most companies
is 70% labor 30% capital now you jump to
a developing world context the operating
cost structure is the inverse it's
typically 70% Capital 30% labor however
all the processes that were created and
fine-tuned in a developer context we're
all around off
amazing labor around labor productivity
makes a lot of sense because that's
where your car cost bulk is and yet as
you migrate into a developing world
context from a company point of view the
opportunities to more intensely use your
capital which is the scarce or the most
expensive one even at the expense of
labour productivity is pretty high and
we've seen examples where companies are
achieving an incremental thirty to forty
percent of the original cost base by
taking advantage of these very different
capital to labor trade-offs to clear
examples to bring it to life that most
of us are familiar with twenty four by
seven operations call center operations
in India not viable in a developer
context why because the labor cost
component is just too high to make that
a viable concept in the indian concept
what is really constrained and expensive
is the computer the telecommunications
equipment the online connection and
maintaining that fully utilized as much
as possible even at the expense of
labour productivity is actually a very
cost efficient thing to do there are all
kinds of examples that we picked up in
across the sector's of this although in
our view companies are just beginning to
understand that India automotive with
smart automation would be another good
example which I can come back to if
you're interested lastly as you all know
when you achieve such dramatic different
cost positions cost production positions
you shift dramatically on the demand
curve and that is in effect what we see
happening and it's everything from the
four thousand dollar car that the India
automotive companies are now creating
for the India market whereas before the
lowest end point was closer to ten
thousand dollars to micro segments of
the developed world that before weren't
scale enough to develop a product store
but at these cost points are sufficient
scale even it's not big enough and again
we see pretty important examples of this
in consumer electronics in
automotive more and more and of course
across all the services dimension of
business process and IT so this is the
bird's eye view of what's happening at
the company level and in fact in our
view wide the very dramatic increases
that we've been seeing in FDI are still
relatively nascent we would expect much
much more because the opportunities for
value creation from a company level view
of these kinds of stages of economic
integration of integrating China and
India and to value chains are enormous
we went through a detailed case study of
the auto sector and concluded that the
saving opportunities for the auto sector
are very large that the revenue
potential because of this dynamic is
even larger and the result of those
together is an increase in the revenue
pool if you want nearly 30 percent of
the current auto sector revenues so very
significant and will continue in our
view but what does saw mean for the
developing countries this is what's
happening to companies and this is the
sector case studies helped inform this
in truth the results were pretty
unequivocal when you look across all 14
case studies what we found is in 13 out
of the 14 case studies the impact was
either positive or very positive in
terms of output productivity employment
product quality and cost
we had one neutral example which I'll
come back to later and most of the the
lower end of this was really in banking
which is explained by the relatively
lower levels of competitive intensity in
banking but this this is just a moment
to pause and I hope you can figure out
the various symbols here for the the
different sectors but the top line is
for 13 out of 14 case studies the net
result was positive now how do we sort
of measure those and and you will if you
have interest can go back to the
detailed case studies but if
highest level we have the impact is
mostly felt on the consumer it's the
consumer in these emerging markets that
sees much much lower prices much higher
quality much better production or choice
in effect and the much-feared impact of
FDI in these markets ie
on employment in restructuring existing
incumbents we found to to be an issue
but there seven out of two thirds out of
all the cases had either positive or
neutral impact on employment in the
third of cases that saw negative impact
on employment we could trace that back
to very bloated existing companies
mostly state-owned enterprises some
quasi monopolies that happened to be in
the private sector and arguably
necessary to have that disruption in
order to achieve the productivity gains
very important as we look at the details
of the sector cases a segmentation on
the motivation of FDI seems to have a
significant impact on how you understand
effect on how you understand the impact
on the host economy and so we saw the
companies that were looking for lower
cost labor basically that were
efficiency seeking companies were all
net positive contributed to the host
economy you saw dramatic increases in
output typically and often in sectors
that didn't exist at all
employment obviously productivity
because best practice was being
transferred immediately and because
these were focused on the export market
and therefore not really and what was
happening to the dynamics of the economy
at home you didn't really see a lot of
the downsides that that that sometimes
are felt by those in the markets
themselves by the same token you didn't
see the same level of benefit to the
consumer because these were really
benefiting global consumers not
necessarily the local consumers in
several instances we did see that impact
on the local consumer as well so we had
the automakers in Mexico in fact
disseminating financing
of auto loads where they hadn't existed
before even though most of the market
was export oriented so there are
instances of that but by and large it
was purely positive impact on output
productivity employment without any
other falling out no surprise this is
what most developing countries try to
focus on is attracting FDI that is
export oriented in nature out on the
other motivation for foreign direct
investment which is really seeking
markets entering those markets in order
to serve the customers in those markets
we saw equally powerful impact but here
the story is is more nuanced
you had very large impact on
productivity across the board
significant impact on output sometimes
negative impact on employment as I said
before as you'd expect and in effect the
cost to the incumbent companies either
the oligopolistic in many cases owners
or the labor that was in those companies
created a lot of the backlash to FDI
that that you we all that you hear about
often now interestingly some of the
markets seeking FDI that goes in is what
we described is tariffs jumping there
are tariffs that don't allow FDI to come
in and so companies that would normally
serve those markets by exporting into
them will set up operations in order to
serve them in those cases we saw the
same kind of benefits across the board
and a lot of impact on the incoming
companies which has a very positive
productivity effect even if it creates a
lot of dislocation
now when we reflect on the benefits that
we saw across the board we concluded
that although overall you had so much
gained the policies in place that are
prevalent in a lot of these countries
suggest is actually room for much much
greater impact from positive impact from
foreign direct investment and so I'm
going to share with you some of the
things that didn't work and why they
didn't work and some of the things that
did work and why we saw them working
many countries have a wide variety of
incentives to FDI of one form or another
either direct incentives cash land tax
subsidies tax breaks of all sorts they
put import barriers precisely in order
to try to attract companies to come in
and enter and they often have other
mechanisms like local content
requirements or other things which are
non trade mechanisms but non trade
limiting mechanisms that have the same
effect of trying to get to create
investment locally from foreigners to
fueled domestic employment now in our
case studies what we learned is that the
impact of all these tools that many of
these countries use is at worse
ineffective at best ineffective in many
cases very detrimental and it's
detrimental not only because it has a
direct cost whether it's the direct
grant or the or the administrative costs
associated with those grants but very
importantly because of the distortive
effects that it creates in the economy
and by and large we could not find a
single example where these had the
desired effect even where you had the
ability you attracted the investment you
created all kinds of negative
productivity outcomes so let me give you
an example of that
Brazil auto sector after the opening up
of FDI Brazilian government has by the
way many state governments in the u.s.
went into a feeding frenzy to try and
attract the OEMs into their marketplace
and they succeeded they managed to get a
lot of investment in but the level of
investment that was attracted was orders
of magnitude higher than any reasonable
market forecast would suggest it's
amazing what you can justify when you
have subsidies the tune of a hundred and
eighty thousand dollars per job created
that's what the level of incentives that
the Brazilian government and that
handing over to the OEMs in effect to
the manufacturers of assembly result was
at least forty percent increased
capacity capacity over and above what
was required and the expected downward
effect on productivity now if those
targeted policies towards FDI don't work
what yes well the different forms of
subsidies but we've seen subsidies in
the form of tax breaks so that companies
are getting tax holiday for pair time
which is a form associate II there are
direct subsidies whereby the government
will give company a land grant or a
literally cash out of hand in the case
of the Brazilian OMS it was in many
cases literally a cheque of money back
to the company to locate in one location
versus another and and I would point out
that that some of this this bidding war
which we see unfortunately in the US -
for plants trying to operate has two
levels it's bad enough that the federal
governments do this in the sense says as
money's coming in but in effect what
often happens is that the states or one
level below the federal government
compete with each other to try and
attract this and in fact bid away an
enormous amount of value what does work
based on these experiences well a couple
of obvious things I'll pick up the first
and the top and the bottom because
they're pretty straightforward
macroeconomic instability is very
essential think about Brazil before the
the stabilization of the route just not
possible to even get FDI attracted in
there but it really is a precondition
to the level of FDI that that we see or
the growth going forward and the bottom
one is the importance of infrastructure
and through many of the surveys that we
did with executives on the ground while
they were actively negotiating the
various subsidies and and other
incentives that they were being offered
they all said 85% of them said not all
85% of them said we would frankly prefer
to have that level investment put into
the infrastructure and this is
particularly true in in sort of the
newest kinds of investments the India IT
and BPO operations and otherwise then
get them directly in subsidies because
in the long run that's just much more
valuable to us so those are pretty
obvious the ones that maybe a little
less obvious and this gets to some of
our punch lines on the FDI is the degree
to which ensuring in addition to
allowing the FDI to come in that that
FDI contributes to the competitive
environment in a meaningful way that
there's a level of competitive intensity
within the sector that enables FDI to
play its role is very very important and
so we find that when people talk about
FDI and why it's important to attract
FDI into developing countries they focus
on its contributing capital
yes it's doing that it's contributing
technology yes it's doing that it's
contributing managerial know-how those
are all very important but just as
importantly and in many cases more
importantly it's that they infuse a
level of competitive dynamic that did
not exist exist in that sector before so
let me before I jump to the next one let
me give you a very clear example of that
India automotive we had
absolutely I think when we describe a
macroeconomic environment we don't mean
it narrowly in the sense of you know
stable inflation or exchange rates we
mean more broadly an environment in
which those risks are mitigated but let
me come back to this question of the
importance of a competitive environment
not just the direct inflow of capital
technology and know-how in the it's a
little bit complicated but I'll give you
the top line this is the case of India
automotive 1995 you saw a new wave of
FDI enter as a result of liberalisation
and not surprisingly you saw a very
dramatic increase in productivity so you
look at the benchmark in the early 90s
at 100 by the end of the day of the
decade productivity had increased by a
factor of three and a half times very
significant productivity improvement
over a relatively short period of time
in a sector that previously had seen
almost no productivity improvement at
all the far right that 84 is the direct
impact of FDI so these are the OEMs that
actually came in and directly
contributed to the productivity in that
sector 25 percent of the impact it's
important it's really part of what the
story is but that's as I said only a
piece of the story in some cases like
this one the more important part of the
story is the way that the introduction
of those best practice and know-how into
the marketplace forces the other
incumbents to act very very differently
and so you see what eight the HM and
Maruti did in response they took the
clunker expensive terrible cars and had
to in effect work hard to get those
customers that was 50 percent of the
impact was just improvements within the
existing incumbents and where those
improvements did not occur it was
literally a forcing out of those
underproductive players so in the case
of pea pea al who was not capable of
making those improvements and responding
competitively they were forced out of
the market
gather together the reaction of the
competition was 75% of the productivity
impact so just to make the point again
because it's so important when people
think so much about FDI and why it's
important to attract it into market they
think about the fact that it's bringing
in capital technology and know-how
that's true and it's important but just
as important is the way in which it
changes the competitive dynamic in the
sector and therefore drives a much
higher level of productivity of all the
players the the the next less obvious
thing that we found and here Maggie's
work was Maggie Maggie was we had the
privilege of having Maggie a time GI
helping to do some of this work in the
retail sector is the ways in which in
some economies particularly in Latin
America economies where there is a very
high degree of informality a gray market
how that really limits the impact of FDI
and so essential is the creation of
level playing field of the enforcement
of the rules whether its tax obligations
social obligations otherwise to ensure
this competitive dynamic can be at play
if you look at the the retail sector in
Brazil you had after the opening up to
FDI in that sector a big on rush of the
retailers their car for Walmart several
others coming in and in fact they did
achieve the kind of productivity
increases that one would expect they
came in did things very differently and
achieved a 32 percent increase in their
direct productivity however they are now
operating with the existing tax
structure and social obligations more
broadly so their net margin disappears
have absolutely no pricing power because
they're competing with large operators
in the market we're basically evading
taxes and therefore have that price
umbrella and that dynamic in effect
keeps a much much greater share of the
retail market with the underproductive
players who are informal and the
tax evasion gives them that sort of
competitive edge so in our view
countries that attract a lot of FDI into
sectors where they don't enforce the
regulations and create smaller incidents
of informality do not get the FDI impact
that they would seek down
so in effect our view is that across all
these cases we see pretty dramatic
positive impact we think there's an
opportunity for greater positive impact
if people understand the dynamic of
foreign direct investment is not
narrowly it's transference of capital
and knowledge but certainly the
competitive dynamic it contributes to
but it's likely to continue pretty
aggressively as we go forward given how
big the value creation opportunities are
for the companies involved so let me
pause there and just open it up for
discussion happy to talk about more of
this case studies or just a more general
discussion
they were both we had instances of entry
and jayvees we had interest as of
Greenfield and brownfields is to say and
the truth is we did some work to try and
see whether there was some interesting
pattern that emerged whether something
was greenfield or or not whether
something was JB or not and it was clear
but they here are a couple observations
on it
one was that clearly when a company can
come in and set up its operations from
scratch a lot easier than when they're
coming in to acquire a company and and
try to achieve the same kind of
productivity gains with a set of
practices that that have been embedded
in the employment base and customer base
and otherwise having said that it there
are times when that falls apart and we
saw for example in the case of Chinese
auto sector where the jayvees were
actually essential for the automakers to
have access to the distribution chain
and so even though they had to live in
some cases they really work meaningful
operations they just had to pay a
partner some amount to to operate there
for any cases where they were taking
over existing operations as painful as
that may have been it was a worthwhile
cost to pay in order to have access to
the distribution mechanism which is just
a very hard thing to operate on so I
don't that that's a way in which we saw
it we saw certain patterns but it was
really hard to to pull across and say
JB's a good bad Green feels better in
the case of JB's what we did conclude
was that JV requirements were were in
some sense is not necessary because
we're the JV had a real value to it
the enters enters typically sought that
JB on their own they understood that in
the case of the distribution story for
example in China where it had no
economic value or where it really was
distorting it
once again contributed to either
dissuading people for going in because
if they can't have majority interest
they're not interested in going in or
where they did go in in distorting the
kinds of outcomes in ways that we that
I've described earlier yes let me take
another question since you asked when
you come back I think that that we
didn't look at small countries so but
but taking a step away from this there's
no question scale plays a huge role
particularly for market seeking foreign
direct investment for efficiency seeking
foreign direct investment by and large
it has played it played less of a role
although clearly people would prefer to
have operations that can serve both
export and domestic markets so there
again the large markets have an interest
I think that the one area where that is
less true and where countries like Chile
and other smaller countries have been
able to get a real foot in even though
their domestic markets aren't large is
in specialized services and so the
offshoring market of services IT and
business process operations yield some
really incredible places people are
going you know people are going to
Morocco French companies are going to
Marco you have Argentina has become a
specialized area for certain kinds of
operations because in those cases what
you're really serving is another outside
market so it's really export oriented
and what you're looking for is a very
specialized set of skills ideally at a
lower cost and you get him otherwise and
a lot of Eastern European countries
would fit that mold South Africa
countries that you would typically
wouldn't think of as attractive
locations when you think about subscale
skill tapping into skills you can do it
now that's good but for a country it's
not big enough to warrant
a lot of them yes do you find a
successful way for customers who are
able to find a way
well you know if you're a China you can
get away with it right because everybody
wants to go to turn it so yes you could
find instances where China has
maintained you know at least parts of
the segment if you think about the
automotive sector buses were not a
segment that was open to FDI so they
maintained all that and in fact were
able to migrate some of the displacement
in from cars into buses where they
attracted a lot of FDI because everybody
was clamoring to get in there and where
they achieved some of the very positive
impact of it so you see in over the
course of 1995 to 2002 which is where we
have the best data the productivity and
output in the Chinese auto sector
increased by over 30 percent a year just
phenomenal right
you had price declines of price declines
declines of 30% when the CPI was
increasing 10%
I mean employment grew dramatically put
aside environmental problems Chinese
creating put and otherwise you'd call
that a success story but they did have
in place some local content requirements
they did have in place JB requirements
they did so they kind of managed to have
the cake and eat it too because their
China and they can do that
we would argue that that as much as they
had their cake and ate it too there was
a cost to them and the cost is like so
many of these discussions about
globalization and otherwise borne by all
consumers across the entire economy and
so you're trading off protection of a
small number of incumbents either the
state-owned enterprises or there or in
countries like Latin America the
oligarchies that owned them and the
employment face behind those which is
significant and you you know you
there's dislocation there it's
concentrated and it's very vocal I guess
what is in effect a much broader but
much smaller impact on
Zoomers and the process of senate of
living improvement and i think that's
the story whether you're talking about
FDI or offshoring or globalization in
general introducing the slow competitive
pressure it has that imbalance dynamic
and one's very vocal and one's not
particularly welcome yes they're talking
about a captive operation of an existing
company
third party can you talk a little bit
about the distinction between the two
and under what circumstances accompany a
US or European company could create more
value by simply setting up a trade
arrangement with an existing out sorting
partner versus actually investing in
their own opera
lung-lung topics so let me give you a
couple of observations and and we have
separately we were asked to come and
talk about FBI we've done a lot of work
on offshoring and so I encourage you I
can encourage all of you to go to our
website and to to look at our work but
let me just answer with a couple of our
sessions you're right that there's a lot
of confusion about what is and what is
not I wish I had some of these charts
with me but they're really two
dimensions of it one is is is it onshore
offshore and the other is is it captive
or is it outsourced really and so you
can think about that matrix and say for
each of those what we see is every one
of those is actually growing the one
that's growing the fastest is offshore
captive operations but the offshore
outsource our beginning to pick up - so
you have all of those elements now
second part of your question was when
does it make sense what doesn't long
story with lots of variations but I
think there are a couple of things to
take into account the the degree to
which people use offshoring as a way to
just obviate what is otherwise good
managerial practice of getting the most
of what you have right now is higher
than then then you would think given how
many managers come out of these great
business holes so many times what we
learn is that the benchmark for savings
and offshore are being done against the
way things are currently done in the
developed world
well that yields enormous level of
savings that's very good
if you instead said okay before we can
do that saving let's talk about how we
take what we have now and bring it to
best practice relative to what exists in
this country and then talk about the
savings still significant savings and
and and and yet not certainly not quite
as high and in some cases not justified
the complication to that story is that
many times I talked about this fourth
and fifth stage a lot of the
opportunities for
for taking advantage of these capital
labor trade-offs suggest that you won't
even get those greater efficiencies if
you're not in that other location and so
you might have written off from a saving
point of view an opportunity that if you
then understood the local conditions
right so it's a very complicated set of
discussions but I think that the first
starting point for it is to recognize
that there are different things we're
talking about and when you take the
lowest to the highest you sometimes get
savings that tell you a different story
then when you take the the real apples
to apples comparisons oh so you know
what I'm talking
we would always tell customers is don't
go to counter proves their habit because
those
because their savings benchmark is here
right there they're just looking to save
relative to a developed world level
they're not looking to achieve five
percent increases or ten fifty percent
increases on their operations exactly I
want to come back to you because you had
a question and I didn't want to skip and
then I'll come back to
bring others successful for example
these are like a starting line
I don't wanna or
from similar industries or different
industry
already I'm sorry I'm not sure I
understand your question do we see
instances of companies replicating
somebody else's success so were you
the success of one industry bring
another
I would say with few exceptions not that
the the industry dynamics are typically
established within a sector and within
the companies that compete in that
sector the exception is when you see
industries colliding where you see what
used to be purely telecommunications and
media begin to look and feel very much
like one industry and then of course you
get those but but we see relatively few
instances you can see examples of a
particular technology that get cement in
one sector and then gets used for other
things but it from a from a broad
industry competitive point of view most
of that is really determined at the
sector level which is why all our work
really comes in to look at these things
from the sector point of view yes
paddle of Chinese government officials
or a Brazilian with whatever you know
you had a strongest pushback and
legitimate kind of contrary conclusion
to what you have on the eye
you seems like some of the punch line or
poor jobs high productivity growth
would have been kind of the strongest
criticism well III think that it's nots
criticism to these conclusions and and
more the political realities in which
governments operate so you think about
how many things in government's
understand what the right answer is and
they're not in a political environment
to be able to do it so you have the
think about the restructuring of the
state-owned enterprises I mean there is
no Chinese bureaucrat that doesn't know
that most of those enterprises are
incredibly bloated and what they really
need if they wanted to achieve higher
productivity and is to fire a lot of
those people well that's the politically
a very very difficult thing to do so I
think that we get back to this
discussion i teed up before about the
the political realities of a small and
truly displace I mean I don't mean in
any way to minimize the dislocation and
difficulty that comes to people who are
faced with these difficulties but those
tend to be very concentrated and very
vocal against a a game that is very
diluted and and not not vocal doesn't
have a constituency and so you come
against time time again these political
issues
take for example local content
requirements you know somebody says well
if the automaker is going to come in
here the least we can get is a whole
supply set of suppliers that are
domestic contributing - it sounds
logical right you create jobs and do all
this all and stuff unfortunately what
you do in effect is create a little
protective barrier around them and they
deliver terrible products and high
prices and that filters all the way back
in on the other hand you've got a very
active local supplier base activating
behind this so you know I think that the
reality is this is where economics and
it's in its simplicity comes against the
complications of apologies
it's good news your audience on the MNC
side who are you informing to what
exactly what decisions does this do you
see people thinking because
well let me take a step back and try to
answer that by saying this I think we
got a great introduction temperature at
the high level but but what McKinsey
Global Institute is is it's a little bit
arm's length
- what McKinsey and company the
consulting arm do certainly in our voice
and what we really it's funded by the
partners of McKinsey we're not
commissioned by anyone to do this work
but the the objective and our target
audience for this is on the one hand
regulators to help regulators understand
the ways in which policy drives better
or worse economic outcomes and I would
say business leaders to the degree that
they are either States people and really
want to understand the way of the world
or we're particularly in the case of
very large multinational companies where
they understand that the dynamics of
their own success is linked to
underlying economic growth for example
and and such now I think I this
presentation as you noted had some two
parts to it one is what's happening at
the company level and then what do we
understand from the regulatory point of
view to the degree that we help
companies understand the world from that
bird's-eye view up once we are green
sectors I think very good strategic
managers find that very very powerful to
thinking about how much or how little
they should be doing certain things and
so we do engage very strongly with our
strategy practice now to work with
executives who are trying to really
understand the way the world works so to
speak
and and and decision makers but not in
the what do I do Monday morning but more
in the long term strategic planning
context or in their role as business and
society yes oh sorry
ya know that that would clearly be one
when I say policymakers I mean in the
broadest sense we spent a lot of time
with the World Bank talking to them
about what we do and working with them
so we take advantage of the things that
they do you know a lot of the
involvement of the World Bank
in this is less than the private sector
angle and so we see them as actually
very complementary yes thanks for
bringing that up it's always sort of an
aside but it's a pretty interesting
story thinking the two cases where we
went in depth on banking were in Brazil
and Mexico and both of those let me
start with Mexico because it's such a
radical story in the span of about five
years the Mexican assets went from I
forget the under 10% for known to 80%
for now
so you know clearly you had massive and
all the big you know you'd recognize all
the names citi bank hsbc hsbc all chaos
anthem it all came in and really just
took over the marketplace the dynamic
process that we described that would
have been wonderful to have something
there do for example what it's done in
Spain and Europe in Brazil didn't occur
because in fact they came into
situations that were pretty comfortable
they acquired banks that had a huge
portfolio of government bonds so they
didn't actually have to scramble to get
loans and where in effect they settled
into a now not domestic oligopoly but
into a foreign oligopoly and banks
unfortunately this sector which we've
looked at time time again lends itself
more to that because of the
characteristics of the industry so it's
very sticky
you know customer sticky customers just
don't switch how often do you go and
check whether your bank is really giving
you the best service so you can go and
switch and fill out all the forms again
and do that so
so really really tick you off before you
switch you have an enormous amount of
regulatory dynamics that cause banks to
collaborate and in effect they're all
just doing the same thing so they have
to provide a lot of information to
regulators the center of the result is
that you don't you have a pretty comfy
environment or hurting thanks to dodge
degree now consolidation has changed a
lot and in the US for example in others
but in these sector cases we really just
didn't see we did see the infusion of
capital into both markets that was
essential we did see some productivity
gains on the operations side but because
a lot of what the banks were doing was
not the traditional banking they were
you know vehicles for the government to
do other things you just didn't have the
same level compared to him it was better
in Brazil than in Mexico but sorry it
was better in Mexico than Brazil but it
was still in neither case was it the
more impressive cases